as local officials exercise their power
over minut infractions Europe examines
ways to reopen debate breaks out in the
United States over how to reopen and
when and the New York Times faults
president Trump for his coronavirus
response while letting Joe Biden off the
hook for an allegation of sexual assault
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressive VPN protect your online
privacy today and express it VPN calm
slash Ben well you may have noticed that
the economy is a little bit volatile
right now by the economy's a little bit
volatile I mean nobody knows where the
stock market is going will it be down 20
percent next month will be up 15 per ton
what the hell is going on
and now might be a good time for you to
think about diversifying into precious
metals I mean if you had listened to me
like a year ago you'd be sitting pretty
right now if you diversified a little
bit into precious metals over 10 million
unemployment claims in March last week
we have like another 7 million
unemployment comes up to 17 million
unemployed to add it to the rolls in
just the last month or so even with the
stock market having a slight recovery we
just don't know the long-term impact of
any of this the prudent thing to do
diversify at least a little bit into
precious metals think of the position
you'd be in now if you had actually done
this before the coronavirus upended
global economies it makes good sense to
diversify you diversify even inside your
stock portfolio why would you not have
versifying in the ways that you hold
your money before May 31st with a
qualifying purchase Birch gold is going
to give you a free emergency kit this
backpack is absolutely loaded with all
the things that are hard to get right
now safeguard your savings with purge
school they'll help you safeguard your
families it's a nice giveaway there's no
obligation to take that first step so
you have nothing to lose Birch gold
group has thousands of satisfied
customers countless five-star reviews
and a plus rating with the Better
Business Bureau don't wait until the
market drops in order to protect your
hard-earned savings techs been - 47 47
47 today
- see how simple and straightforward the
move can be for you again that's my name
been Tex been to 47 47 47 today see how
simple and straightforward the move is
Birch gold they're the people I trust
with precious metals investing you
should call them right now ask all your
questions and find out why again text my
name Ben - 47 47 47 right now ok so here
is your coronavirus update I've been off
for a few days
thanks to Passover which frankly it was
nice because one of the big problems of
Twitter is that you're checking every
five minutes to see if they have
developed a vaccine and in fact they
have not developed a vaccine nor have
they developed any reliable treatments
for coronavirus and so basically you're
just spinning your wheels 24 hours a day
which is why disconnecting is actually
kind of a good thing I hope that people
did that a little bit over the beginning
of Passover and did that also over
Easter right now in the United States
we've seen approximately 22,000 total
deaths a little over 22,000 total
deaths we are starting to see the slow
take place actually yesterday was a
little bit down according to world
ometer which was gathered from the Johns
Hopkins information they suggest that
there are about 1500 1500 new deaths
yesterday the peak was already hit
according to that University of
Washington study it happened a couple of
days ago and so this has got people
talking as they should be talking about
reopening the economy and what that
looks like the big problem in reopening
the economy and what that looks like is
this great fear of a second wave and as
I mentioned I've been talking about this
for a long time one of the things that's
very irritating about the way the news
is covered is the reduction to absolute
simple stupidity it's really irritating
so for the last few weeks we've been
treated to flatten the curve flatten the
curve flat in the curve and I've been
all in on that flatten the curve right
stay home make sure that you are not
going out and make sure that if you are
going out you're socially distancing
masks are probably a good idea right
here in Los Angeles they now have rules
that if you go into a grocery store an
enclosed area you have to be wearing a
mask they shut down pretty much every
Park in LA yesterday which frankly seems
to me like overkill you actually want
people outside in outdoor areas staying
away from each other and I think people
are smart enough not to get on top of
each other for the most part but with
all of that said I've been all in on the
on the measures that have been
recommended by doctor foul Qi and by dr.
Burks in terms of the social distancing
but I've been saying all along that the
big question here is going to be what
happens when we are all released from
our home confinement because that's what
this is what's going to happen when we
go back out there are we gonna reinfect
each other what's the plan for us not to
reinfect each other how exactly do you
plan for something like that when for
the first week of having coronavirus
apparently it is asymptomatic or at
least not obviously symptomatic to
people who are outside what happens when
you have a slight cough it doesn't feel
like coronavirus and you're being told
that you're supposed to lockdown for 14
days in allergy season hey how is any of
that supposed to work how are we
supposed to work an economy which is
gonna lose 40% of GDP according to JP
Morgan just this quarter how are we
supposed to get back into an economy
when we don't know whether a second wave
is gonna break out or even what a second
wave looks like at this point and so the
only information that we have so far is
looking to foreign countries and trying
to see how they are doing it and the
answer is that they are handling it in a
variety of ways and it is not clear
which way is going to be the best so in
Italy actually they are still extending
their business
lockdown despite pressure according to
the achons phones press Italian Prime
Minister Giuseppe Conti on Friday
refused to bow to business pressure and
extended the Mediterranean countries
economically crippling lockdown until
May 3rd Conti made the announcement
after Italy's official covin 19th hole
plan by another v 570 fatalities to 18
thousand 849 more than any other country
but with the growth rate now just a
fraction of what it was a few weeks ago
so they have successfully begun to
flatten the curve media reports say
business unions from regions responsible
for 45% of Italy's production and 80% of
its coronavirus deaths had written to
content warning the companies would be
unable to pay wages if the shutdown runs
on but consi said that Italy could not
afford another spike in infections and
needed to exercise caution in the face
of new disease there's been talk in
China of a spike in cases again plus
there are new federal projections that
show a huge spike in corona virus
infections in the summer in the United
States if current lockdown and social
power social distancing measures are
lifted after the planned 30 days
according to the UK Daily Mail new US
government figures showed that a spike
in corona virus infections would occur
in the summer if the current lockdown
measures are lifted after 30 days as
planned that would be at the end of
April presumably about 95 percent of the
United States is currently on some form
of lockdown after President Trump issued
the guidelines calling for 30 days of
measures to slow the spread of the virus
the government projections obtained by
the New York Times indicate that lifting
the strict social distancing measures
now in place will see a second wage
surge second wave surge in infections
and deaths and about June and July if
the current shelter and place orders are
lifted on May 30th the death toll is
estimated to reach 200,000 according to
the projections obtained from the
department's of Homeland Security and
Health and Human Services so far the
United States has seen only about 22,000
us which is a lot of deaths in a short
period of time 200,000 deaths by the end
of the summer would obviously wildly
exceed the numbers that are being put
forth and for example that University of
Washington study which was downgraded to
about 60,000 deaths if we all stay home
through the end of May the death toll
could reach 300,000 without any
restrictions imposed to contain
coronavirus including school closing
shelter and place orders and social
distancing so as I've been saying for a
long time we may have been simply buying
time for the medical system to ramp up
its ICU beds and its ventilators to the
point where at least you will have an
ICU bed and a ventilator
you need one but we can't actually save
you we've bought ourselves a few weeks
time in order to develop some treatments
we bought a few weeks time at toward a
vaccine but there's a lot of talk about
the idea that the vaccine is still not
gonna be developed for 12 to 18 months
which means that what are we gonna do
lock down for 12 to 18 months have these
periodic rolling lock downs for 12 to 18
months other countries are trying to
struggle with exactly what this looks
like
during the White House briefing on
Friday president Trump said he and his
advisors have not yet seen the new
coronavirus projections
he gave a different projection he said
he thinks the United States will lose
fewer than the 100,000 lives initially
projected to be lost to coronavirus
suggested the country is nearing its
peak infection rate but you've heard dr.
fowey say things like well maybe we'll
reopen the schools and fall I have no
idea how you are gonna reopen the
schools involve this thing is still
around and then not reinfect everybody
okay I have three kids who are under the
age of seven my six-year-old and my
soon-to-be four-year-old if they go back
to school they're gonna reinfect each
other that's just the way this is gonna
work kids are germ factories they'll
reinfect each other they'll come on over
Grandma and Grandpa will have to stay
home presumably for the duration or
Grandma and Grandpa run a significant
likelihood of being infected schools
will become a wellspring for this sort
of stuff unless you end up with the
strategy that maybe we should have
attacked in the first place which would
have been to keep the most old and most
vulnerable home and let everybody else
go back to work including social
distancing in masks maybe that should
have been the program from the very
beginning because that looks in all
likelihood like what's going to have to
happen here over the course of time now
there are certain ways that we can
alleviate some of those burdens there
have been there's been talk about
widespread testing that would allow
people to go back to factories and and
social distancing measures and apps that
will allow us to warn people if
somebody's infected with Korah virus and
lock things down in hot spots but that
doesn't solve the problem for people who
are most vulnerable it doesn't solve the
problem for people who are elderly it
doesn't solve the problem for people who
have pre-existing conditions and doctor
foul she warned that if the United
States prematurely and social distancing
measures they're right back in the same
situation so that second wave that
apparently only I was talking about or
very few people we're talking about is
very much real and this is what drove me
nuts throughout the entire conversation
people were saying okay we got a lock
down we got a lock down we got a lock
down and they weren't being clear with
the American public what exactly we were
attempting to do if the idea was we were
locking down just so we can ramp up our
medical resources then okay our medical
resources are now ramped up there is no
there are no four warnings that the
United States medical system is going to
be overrun at this point in New York
medical system was not in fact overrun I
mean Governor Cuomo said this last week
they did not run in short on ICU beds
they did not run short on ventilators
they were not splitting ventilators or
at least if they were it was in rare
circumstances where there were holdups
in the supply chain we'll get to more of
this in a second because there are no
easy decisions to be made here and I'm
getting kind of sick of people who are
Pro shutdown suggesting the easy
decision is just to lock things down
indefinitely and people who are anti
shutdown suggesting that the easy
decision is just to go back to
everything is normal because I don't
think that's right and I think there are
costs and benefits on each side and I
don't think this is easy in any way and
anybody who's telling you it's easy is
lying to you anybody who's telling you
this is an easy calculation is not
looking what's happening in other parts
of the world
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that there are things that we each look
back on and we think how could I
possibly have gotten it so wrong like
for example over Passover you just eat
tons of matzah without any foresight as
to how this is going to affect your
digestive system how did I get it so
wrong well perhaps there are many things
in life you've gotten wrong but one
thing you can't afford to get wrong is
your life insurance hey you need to get
your life insurance right chop for life
insurance of policy genius policy genius
makes finding the right life insurance a
breeze in minutes you can compare quotes
from the top insurers and find your best
price it could save 1,500 bucks or more
a year by using policy genius to compare
life insurance policies once you apply
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork and the red tape for free
and policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy they can also help you
find the right home and auto insurance
or disability insurance like if you're a
responsible human being you want to make
sure that your family is taken care of
in case god forbid something should
happen to you life insurance policies
are a really good idea all the time and
they are especially a good idea right
now go check out policy genius.com right
now again that's policy genius.com
everybody makes mistakes from time to
time don't make a mistake from your life
insurance policy genius.com else offer
to the home in the auto the disability
insurance all your insurance needs met
at policy genius comm go check them out
right now okay so what is going on in
Europe well bunch of different sort of
measures being taken by different
countries so Italy is still locked down
because Italy was hardest hit and that
is where they are most afraid that the
medical system continues to be very
fragile and possibly overrun meanwhile
CNN reports people in the Czech Republic
can now shop at hardware and bicycle
stores play tennis and go swimming
Austria plans to reopen
smaller shops after Easter Denmark will
reopen kindergartens and schools from
next week if coronavirus cases remain
stable children in Norway will return to
kindergarten
a week later these nations are the first
in the West to start feeling their way
gradually out of the limits on daily
life imposed by governments to curb the
spread of coronavirus for professional
athlete or in a killer ova from the
Czech Republic the easing of
restrictions Thursday meant she could
return to training at the Jewish cos
stadium in Prague for the first time
since her country walked down it was
great honestly I was full of excitement
I feel great she said dr. Peter drew
back a global health expert at Oxford
Saeed Business School told CNN country
is now easing their restrictions are
important in hopeful examples for the
West but any loosening of limits will
carry risk w-h-o Regional Director of
Europe dr. Hans club won this week that
the situation in Europe is so very
concerning concerning and insisted now
is not the time to relaxed measures so
it is unclear exactly how far the the
relaxation of measures are going to go
according to drawback who is according
to drøbak who is one of the commentators
on this particular issue that that
global health expert at oxford say
Business School he said the country is
preparing to ease restrictions had
something in common they were among the
first in Europe to implement lock downs
or severe social distancing measures and
had rapidly scaled up coronavirus
testing he said that the plans for
relaxed restrictions look reasonable and
they look smart it's a gradual process
they'll be able to learn and track
things in terms of new infections if
they ease up too much in infections it
starts to spike they can pull back a bit
that's how every country is going to
have to do its what we're gonna have is
basically a stop-start model right first
they need to have bent the curve second
their health system needs to be able to
cope so far that looks like the United
States third they need a system in place
for mass testing contact tracing and
isolation so sick people can be isolated
before they infect others and that's
what everybody sort of wishes that they
had done from the beginning Denmark has
plans to send kids back to school in
kindergarten from April 15th if
coronavirus cases remains stable a life
will still look far from normal
many restrictions will remain in place
there's still a ban on gathering some
more than 10 people that's been extended
until May 10th church services cinemas
shopping centers are remaining closed
festivals and large gatherings remain
closed all the way until August at
Denmark's borders that remain shut that
was one of the first countries in Europe
to shut its borders they did that on
March 13th they closed schools cafes and
shops as well as been and gathering some
more than 10 people and visits to the
hospital
in Czech Republic they moved swiftly to
impose restrictions on travel ban large
events and closed non-essential
businesses after declaring a state of
emergency on March 12 also they required
their 11 million people to cover their
faces with masks or scarves when outside
the home from March 19th since Tuesday
people have been allowed to exercise
alone without phase masks shops such as
construction and hardware stores bicycle
stores bicycle repair sensors are
allowed to reopen from Thursday bikes
are big obviously in the Czech Republic
outdoor facilities for individual sports
are reopening but only to some extent no
more than two people can be in the same
space they can't use the showers or the
lockers and essential travel outside the
Czech Republic will be allowed from
April 14th alone in Austria they are
also attempting a step-by-step approach
Austrian Chancellor Sebastian kurz
announced this week the country is
preparing for a resurrection after
Easter reopening some small shops
hardware and garden stores from April
14th they are requiring people to our
face masks to supermarkets and on public
transportation from May 1st all shops
shopping centres and hairdressers will
open meanwhile restaurants and hotels
will open from mid-may at the earliest
in a gradual process and he said that
the situation is not yet over citing
Singapore because Singapore has seen a
second wave of cases in Norway Norway is
prioritizing reopening of schools
they're gonna scale back their lockdown
measures from April 20th they're going
to reopen kindergartens the government
believes the latest stats provide the
basis for cautious optimism right now
they've only been 92 deaths
in Norway Germany is also attempting
some new measures and then what's really
fascinating is that the world's largest
scale counter example of all of this is
Sweden so there's a lot of talk early on
about Sweden taking a very different
model than everybody else Sweden looking
at the at the way everybody else was
locking down and saying ok guys you're
locking down you're gonna get a second
wave what if we just kind of let
everybody go about their business and
then we told everybody who was old and
everybody who had pre-existing
conditions to stay home that was sort of
Sweden took some measures but not total
measures like in restaurants you just
weren't supposed to eat at the counter
you're now supposed to eat at socially
distance tables for example
so how's Sweden performing right now
well Sweden has seen a grand total of
919 deaths out of some 11,000 cases in
Sweden there's a lot of talk about
Sweden spiking that was expected I was
always bewildered by the media coverage
of Sweden because the suggestion was
that they had not expected some sort of
spike no they sort of did
that was baked into the cake and the
fact is that if you look at population
by millions who have died Sweden is not
wildly outlined from other European
countries Sweden has seen 91 deaths per
million population Switzerland had seen
130 Netherlands has seen a hundred and
sixty-five Belgium has seen 337 now of
course the the number of deaths is large
per million is largely reflective of the
fact that these are very very small
populations if you look at Germany
Germany still at 36 the United States is
still at 67 but virtually every other
country in in Europe is actually has a
worse record in deaths per million then
Sweden does so for all the talk Laos
Sweden blew it and Sweden looks worse
than a lot of other countries that's
just not true it really is not okay so
it'll be interesting to see over the
course of the year whether Sweden ends
up having done the right thing or
whether they have done the wrong thing
so all of this has ramifications for the
United States because how exactly are we
going to reopen what is our strategy
going to be and as I'm going to discuss
in just a moment the answer is gonna be
data data and more data okay well
everybody is trying to kick the can down
the road when the data starts to roll in
is time to make some tough decisions and
I'm sick of hearing that the decisions
are not tough that they're easy and then
anybody who suggests gradual reopening
or even serious reopening is poo-pooing
death or that anybody who is who is
calling for shutdowns is poo-pooing the
economy I don't think that's true at
least for the people who are in the
decision-making positions I think that's
that's very true in the commentary and I
think in the comment area they're a
group of people who basically have a
stake and suggesting that anyone who
says the word economy wants people to
die and group of people who have a stake
in the suggestion that anybody who says
the word shut down wants people to be
unemployed and the answer is we're gonna
have to draw a middle line here because
there will come a point here where the
costs do outweigh the benefits President
Trump is not wrong about that that's
what public policymaking is all about
and to pretend that even discussing the
public policy is some sort of verboten
sin is disgusting frankly is the biggest
public policy decision that not only
Trump is ever gonna have to make but
pretty much anybody's gonna ever have to
make to pretend that there are no there
are no sort of stakes on either side is
idiocy of the highest order we're gonna
get some more of this in just one second
first let's talk about now being a very
very good time to take care of your mind
and body so I know it's so tempting in
the middle of this whole thing to sit
home and just eat ice cream I know it
really is like right now you're like
okay I can't go to the gym
it's hard to work out outdoors cuz now I
gotta wear a mask like what the hell am
I supposed to do I'm just gonna sit here
and I need comfort food and I'm gonna
watch old episodes of friends well now
actually is a good time if you can do it
it's a great time to make your mood
better it's a great time to make your
body better it's a great time to
actually improve your health and it's
actually really important because if you
actually fall down the well of I'm gonna
watch old episodes of friends all day
and eat ice cream and do nothing but
that not only will you be disappointed
with yourself on the other end you're
more likely to be depressed in the here
and now this is why you need new numa's
the habit changing solution that helps
users learn to develop a new
relationship with food through
personalized courses you can also
connect to other new muses and build a
healthy community based in psychology
noone teaches you why you do the things
you do empowers you with the tools you
need to break bad habits and replace
them with better ones now's the time
when a lot of your good habits are being
broken instead why not break those bad
habits and create new good habits Noom
has one of the biggest most accurate
food databases available lets you track
meal habits visualize portion size to
see calorie density at a glance
everybody is strapped for time an oddly
feels like you have no time even though
like literally nothing is going on in
the world noone just asks you to commit
10 minutes a day to taking care of
yourself I've been using new my parents
have been using new you should be using
new now is a great time to change your
psychology about health you don't have
to change it all in one day small steps
do make big progress sign up for your
trial today at noon that's a no m.com
slash Shapiro yeah nothing to lose visit
Noom comm slash Shapiro start that trial
today again n om accom slash Shapiro
Noom comm slash Shapiro go check them
out right now ok so the reason this is
becoming increasingly urgent also is
because whenever you have massive
government interventions like this petty
tyrants feel the necessity to go
overboard it's really an unfortunate
thing but petty tyrants feel the
necessity to go completely crazy so over
in Michigan Gretchen Whitmer who was
briefly considered a possible VP
candidate for for Joe Biden she's
basically been shutting down everything
in the world according to the Detroit
News Bob King 62 is a little bored these
days that's because his business being
our lawn care in Ferndale has been
shuttered since Governor Gretchen
Whitmer's first stay-at-home order last
month King runs his company with his son
Ian's about a hundred clients and four
full-time employees more during peak
summer and winter months this is the
time of year when he's usually busy
cleaning up the vestiges of winter
and prepping yards for mowing no such
luck this spring King like hundreds of
other small business owners around
Michigan have been hoping the governor
would ease some restrictions on business
operations in the latest iteration of
her executive order especially for jobs
done largely outdoors that inherently
comply with social distancing he says if
I'm working outside I'm not working next
to somebody I'm working like I'm one
side lawn and this is true but whitmer
not only ignored common-sense changes to
her decree that goes through April 30th
she doubled down on her initial decree
so instead of of changing and allowing
essential workers to include people who
are you know mowing lawns for example
instead she just sort of she just
insisted essentially that everybody go
home they to pretend that all
non-essential activities are
equivalently dangerous his absolute
idiocy she was also ranked over the
coals whitmer was for part of the order
that basically suggested that
non-essential areas of stores like
Target ought to be shut off so instead
of you just going to the target Hey look
there's a toy section of Target I'm
gonna bring a toy home to my kid that
she shut off sections of those stores
including ones where you can buy baby
seats and Gretchen what more is like I'm
not barring the sale of baby seats no
you're just telling businesses that sell
baby seats as well as groceries they
have to shut off the baby seat section
I'm sorry this whole thing is ridiculous
okay these sorts of when I say the whole
thing I don't mean all shot downs I mean
the whole attempt by governor government
to shut down obviously on obviously safe
areas is insane
again I drove around LA yesterday and
number one it goes down and number two I
mean is there a reason why large public
areas should not be open seriously like
people need to see the Sun if you want
to create pee you want to create it
didn't put us for people to get out of
the house and just disobey government
orders I can't think of a better way to
do it than shutting down every public
park in California
it's basically insane it's basically
insane and if you want to make sure that
people are socially distancing at those
parts then fine have a cop at the park
telling people to socially distance so
first of all I don't know who in the
world is like I'm gonna get right up on
top of other people at the park right
now is there anybody who wants to do
that like two Sundays ago I took my kids
out for a picnic and there were people
at the park and you know what we all did
naturally we spread each other we spread
out like 40 feet apart from each other
nobody wants to be on top of each other
I don't know of those
I don't want them coughing on my parents
okay but it's not it's not just
restricted to blue states cops in
Mississippi shut down a drive-in church
service over the weekend held by
Reverend James Hamilton of the King
James Baptist Church in Greenville
Mississippi this is total insanity
Greenville mayor Eric Simmons bans all
in person church services as part of the
state's shelter in place order to stop
the spread of coronavirus but this is a
drive in service people were in their
own cars what the hell are you doing
what are you even talking about people
were parked end to end okay so that
means that they are in even if their
windows are open they're six feet apart
and the cops came and they shut it down
suggesting this was some sort of danger
can we use a little bit of sample here
sample is the Yiddish word for common
sense can use a little bit of common
sense here or are we going to be doomed
to the petty tyranny of idiots is that
we're gonna do you hear that
and again the stronger these measures
get the more people are just going to
ignore them you actually want people to
pay attention to the measures
don't be stupid about it like when I go
to the grocery store people are
involuntarily putting on the masks
before anybody was saying anything cuz
you know what people don't want to do
die it turns out for the same reason
people are watching Trump's Trump's
press conference not because he's so
popular but because they want to have
the information so they do not die
people are taking voluntarily the
measures necessary so they do not die
can rely on the American people at least
a little bit when it comes to matters of
common sense okay in just a second we'll
get to the new war that apparently is
breaking out between President Trump and
Anthony ouchy it is a dumb war it is
stupid there is no purpose to it and
then we're gonna talk a little bit about
what preliminary steps would look like
like what exactly needs to needs to
happen here and what the data is because
I think that by the end of the I'm
optimistic the by the end of the week we
are going to have much more information
much more data to input into our
decision-making model we'll get to that
in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that now would be a great
time to own a gun like seriously now is
a great time to a gun when there's great
uncertainty when there's great
volatility now's a great times and feel
like you are safe in your home because
you just don't know what the hell is
going to happen next I mean let's be
frank about this the idea of civil
unrest is not out of the realm of
possibility as this thing continues for
long periods of time and as people
aren't getting their government checks
and stuff beyond that you've got local
governments that are shutting down local
jails and letting criminals out of jail
because they don't want covert spreading
in jail let's save
crime rates that are going up businesses
being hit I mean really like it's it's
really bad now would be a good time for
you to exercise the second Amendment
right starting a garage buy Marine
veteran more than two decades ago Bravo
Company manufacturing builds a
professional-grade product built to
combat standards that's because BCM
believes the same level of protection
should be provided to every American
regardless if they're a private citizen
or a professional the people of BCM
assume that when a rifle leaves their
shop it will be used in a life-or-death
situation by a responsible citizen law
enforcement officer or soldier overseas
so every components of a BCM rifle is
hand assembled and tested to a
life-saving standard the people of BCM
feel it is their moral responsibility as
Americans to provide tools that will not
fail when it is not just a paper target
BCM also works with leading instruction
instructors of marksmanship from top
levels of Americans at Special Ops
forces from Marine Corps force
reconnaissance so US Army Special Ops
forces teaching you the skills necessary
to defend yourself your family or others
there's a reason I own a gun I've been
concerned about safety for a long time
now it'd be a good time to get a gun
right now Bravo Company manufacturing
head on over to Bravo Company MFG comm
you can discover more about their
products special offers upcoming news
they are awesome folks check them out
help their business Bravo Company MFG
dot-com and check out their fun videos
while you're added to youtube.com slash
Bravo Company USA youtube.com slash
Bravo Company USA ok so in the midst of
all of this the dirty little secret has
been and I've been saying this for weeks
the experts don't know that much they
don't they know what they don't know but
they're not conveying to us what they
don't know and that's a problem because
once once they know what they know then
we can actually start expecting some
some hard facts from them but we've seen
the models change we've seen the numbers
come down but they're not telling us
what they don't know and what further
inputs they need we don't know what
inputs they're using for case fatality
right we keep hearing case fatality rate
being reported the one thing we do know
is that that case fatality rate is not
real we know that the the denominator is
wrong because many more people have
corona virus or corona virus antibodies
then have been tested and we also know
that the numerator is probably not
correct at the number of people who are
dead from corona virus is probably too
low so we don't know anything okay we
don't know any of the statistics that we
need to know and this makes a huge
difference because remember that
Imperial College model this is the one
that was used as sort of worst case
scenario lock it all down suggested that
over the course of the next year 2.2
million Americans could die if we all do
nothing or if we all just go out and no
social distancing no nothing
right and then it said okay well if you
socially distance then it won't be
anything call anything close to that the
Imperial College model was used as the
basis for the Trump administration
shutting things down but that was based
on certain assumptions about the level
of infection in the population as well
as the level of of death from that
infection right they were using
statistics from Italy in wuhan in large
part and so the question becomes okay
well what if what if this thing is more
transmissible than the flu but maybe
twice as deadly as the flu as opposed to
ten times as deadly as the flu what then
right well what are we gonna do at that
point is that a situation where we
basically say to everybody who is in the
least likely populations to be effective
to go back to work because one thing
that we do know is that the death rates
for people who are young and healthy is
significantly lower than people who are
old and have pre-existing conditions if
you're above the age of 80 this thing is
really bad if you have pre-existing
conditions this thing is truly awful now
that doesn't mean there aren't two
outlying cases of young healthy people
dying from it there are one of the big
questions about this thing is whether it
is actually kovat that is driving the
respiratory syndrome that leads to death
or whether it's the immune response to
kovat that's actually driving this there
are some scientific theories out there
that suggest that it might be a you know
sponsz that is too strong and you get a
and you get a I believe it's called a
cytokine storm
now you can a cytokine storm the a storm
in which basically your body's your your
body attacks itself effectively because
the immune response is so strong to
kovat that might explain why there's
such a differential response among
different people because there's a
biological response agent that is
different in every single human being
your immune system differs from person
to person okay with all of that said we
don't know a lot of that information but
that information I think this week is
going to be forthcoming there's some
preliminary estimates that are sort of
fascinating and I want to get to those
according to Reason magazine over the
weekend preliminary results are out from
a Cove at 19 and case cluster study in
one of the region's worst hit by
Germany's coronavirus epidemic and they
are in fact somewhat reassuring one
often heard statistic is the case
fatality rate this afternoon that figure
stands at 3.5% for kovat in the US but
that rate is really inflated as I say
because it doesn't count asymptomatic
cases or undiagnosed people or
recovering at home over the last two
weeks
German virologist tested nearly 80% of
the population
of gang gelt for antibodies that
indicate whether they had been
previously infected by the corona virus
around 15% had been infected allowing
them to calculate a Koba 19 infection
fatality rate of about 0.3 7% the
researchers also concluded that people
who recover from the infection are
immune to reinfection at least for a
little while for comparison us infection
fatality rates from the 1957-1958 flu
epidemic was about 0.27%
for the flu epidemic in 1918 was about
2.6 percent for seasonal flu the rate
typically averages around 0.1% basically
the German researchers found that the
corona virus kills about four times as
many infected people than seasonal flu
viruses do so as I say you would have a
high a higher death rate than flu but
not an exponentially higher death rate
or a or an order of magnitude higher
death rate as people were originally
suggesting that doesn't mean a lot of
people won't die it also doesn't mean
that that some young people won't die it
does mean that we would have to think
about different segments of the
population very differently also there's
a study over the over the weekend that
suggests that perhaps the Cova 19 deaths
were actually hitting California in
February in January and February
according to dr. Jeff Smith a physician
in the chief executive of the who is the
chief executive of the Santa Clara
County government he told County leaders
in a recent briefing that there might
have been a traumatic viral surge in
February in California he said that
maybe Kovan 19 was actually in
California a lot longer than we first
believed maybe like back in December
he said symptoms are very much like the
flu if you got a mild case of kovat you
didn't really notice you didn't even go
to the doctor the doctor maybe didn't
even do it because they presumed it was
the flu
so in January in February there was very
little community testing so one of the
things we have to find out is how far
this thing has gone in California if it
turns out that community infection is
too far gone for us to do sort of
hotspot testing at this point that the
lockdown will not prevent community
reinfection because it's gonna be hard
to trace everybody and we're not gonna
get the systems out in place then
perhaps our best hope is that a lot of
people out there actually have this
thing so we're closer to hurt immunity
than originally thought now I know herd
immunity has become a dirty word except
for Sweden where they're actually
attempting to push it in the UK they
tried the herd immunity strategy and
then they realized they were gonna
overrun their hospitals but if our
hospitals are not going to be overrun
and if the alternative is 18 months of a
near shutdown
then people are gonna have to start
talking about whether that is plausible
or not now we're not gonna know that
based on the data we're not gonna know
that until the data is in there's some
studies that are supposed to come out
later this week and personally know
scientists who are working on this right
now or attempting to establish how many
people have actually gotten this thing
in California in New York once we know
the actual case fatality rate then we as
a society are gonna have some decisions
to make about how we deal with this
let's say for example that the case
fatality rate is 0.37 percent like it is
in Germany let's say that that's the
actual case fatality rate and let's say
that that's an average of all the people
who are dying but let's say that the
real case fatality rate for people who
are above the age of 80 the case
fatality rate is 17% or 18% which is
what it sort of has been so far let's
say that it is let's say that basically
everybody who guys who when they're 80
is identifying it there were a few
asymptomatic eight-year-olds let's say
that everybody who let's say it's in a
15% case fatality rate among 80 year
olds let's say it's a 10 percent case
fatality rate among 7 year olds let's
say that it's a three percent case
fatality rate among 60 year olds and
let's say that it's a point is point
zero point one percent case fatality
rate among people under 40 so the same
is the flu at that point who's hit
everybody who's under 40 and healthy go
to work and everybody else you know
gauge your own level of risk that's a
serious question because again huge
industries are being shut down now we're
not just talking about local restaurants
right we're talking with the entire
airline industry no one is getting into
a canister in the sky with 200 strangers
right now the airline industry is going
to be shut for the foreseeable future
and masks are not gonna do a damn thing
about it
hey so if you want to reans if you want
to restart the economy at a certain
point these tough decisions are going to
have to be made now none of this is
being forwarded by our claim to media
who have an interest in sort of the the
not that the hard questions but the
questions of of the political
ramifications you know how is this going
to hurt Trump and how is Trump handling
all this stuff if your lodestar is still
Trump in the middle of all this if Trump
is the first thing that comes to mind in
the middle of a pandemic I think that
you're doing being human and being an
analyst wrong that is not the way that
you should be thinking about this stuff
here we're gonna get to more of this in
just one second first being locked
inside right now requires double the
excitement and what could possibly be
more exciting than wait for it
jus leftists ears tumblers not just one
two
because - as it has been rumored is
indeed more than one what is this
sorcery you ask well right now when you
become a daily wire insider plus or
all-access member you get a second
leftist years tumblr I am not lying to
you I'm not kidding with Bernie Sanders
now out of the race for president one
tumblr was not enough to hold all of the
tears the tumblers are overflowing
existing members it's natural to feel a
little bit jealous but we have a special
offer coming up just for you daily wire
members get many amazing benefits
including of course that irreplaceable
magnificent inimitable leftist here's
tumblr you get an ad-free
website experience you get access to all
of our live broadcasts our show library
the full three hours of the ben shapiro
show access to the mailbag and now
exclusive election inside op-eds from me
daily where members also get to ask us
questions during backstage our new all
accessed here allows you to join in live
online to nays with me and the other
host in fact i have one tonight so again
become an insider plus or all-access
member double your tears or the tears of
others with two leftist ears tumblers go
to daily wire.com slash subscribe to get
started get 10% off with promo code
Shapiro that's daily wire.com /
subscribe coupon code Shapiro and get
the rarest of all beverage vessels x - x
- how magical we are the largest fastest
corn conservative podcast and radio show
in the nation
[Music]
you
so what would be really wonderful at
this point is the straight scoop from
our public health professionals what
information do they lack what
information do they need and what
information when input into their
thought making processes would lead to
what sort of solutions and we're not
getting any of that honestly I think dr.
fowey is great in a lot of ways this is
one area where I think he has really
been bereft I think the same thing is
true basically of dr. Burks I think that
our public health professionals need to
be fully honest with us as to what they
don't know now I think that they are
saying it right I think that in their
writings they're saying it I think that
when they speak long-form they're saying
it but I think that they need to be
saying listen right now like be honest
with us just be honest okay here's the
data we're missing here's the data we
need we can't make a decision to reopen
until we have this data that's what's
happening here right so dr. pouchy said
over the weekend this has been his
constant refrain that the virus decides
when we reopened that's not true
we decide when we reopen right we do now
we could make a horrible decision we
could make a great decision but we are
the ones who decide we take in all that
the device doesn't side a damn thing the
virus is is not a decision-making tool
right the virus is not the one who's
sitting in the White House the virus is
is is not the virus is a is a horrible
horrible thing that is happening right
now and we are going to have to deal
with that and the other horrible thing
that's happening right now is which is
the destruction of tens of millions of
American jobs and hundreds of thousands
of American businesses we're gonna have
to make those calls and I think it is
MIT frankly I think it's manifestly
irresponsible for people to consistently
go around saying things like it's gonna
become eminently clear when we can
reopen based on the virus no it is not
if it were then Europe wouldn't be
struggling with it right now China
wouldn't be struggling Singapore
wouldn't be struggling everyone is
struggling with this right now
you know why these are tough decisions
and there are no good answers sometimes
all the answers are crappy the kind of
ease like this annoys me the virus that
the virus is not making the decision now
I know what foul Chi is trying to say
which is that we don't have enough data
so just say that say we don't have
enough data once we have the data then
we can start making some tough calls
about what is the best possible way for
us to decide between risk to risk to
life on the one hand and risk to quality
of life and freedom which it turns out
is kind of an important thing in America
I don't know about you but I don't want
to live like this for another 18 months
I don't think many people do anyway
here's dr. fat you suggesting the fire
risk decides when when we reopen the
virus kind of this
whether or not it's gonna be appropriate
to open or not what we're seeing right
now are some favorable signs as I've
discussed with you a few times on this
show it's looking like that in many
cases particularly in New York we're
starting to see a flattening and a
turning around we would want to say I
would want to see a clear indication
that you were very very clearly and
strongly going in the right direction
because the one thing you don't want to
do is you don't want to get out there
prematurely and then wind up your bag
back in the same situation right of
course nobody wants that but that
presumably is why you're ramping up the
ICU beds while you're ramping up the
ventilators while you're ramping up the
treatments and again nobody has offered
a path out of this that doesn't involve
second wave infections borrowing massive
testing regimes like I'm still confused
about that particular policy okay like
there's been a lot of talk about we need
massive testing and then we need contact
tracing is that realistic I mean serious
question is that realistic are we gonna
have tests available like now on-demand
five-minute tests they can test you for
antibodies because you don't have to
have a fever you don't have to be
running a fever to be carrier to be
carrying coronavirus are we gonna test
everybody like once a day once every two
days 300 million people 165 million
people in the workforce like what does
that actually look like is that is that
a realistic thing or we wait for the
symptoms to crop up and once the
symptoms crop up then we go back and
retrace every contact that you've had
over the past two weeks at which point
in places like New York it's gonna be a
little bit too late alright that may be
possible in some smaller areas that are
more spread out that is not nearly
possible in New York as they found out
now Falchi again Falchi then adds to
that loosening restrictions will get and
loosening restrictions can get us
infected again yes I know so how do you
plan to accomplish this thing well if
you start and when one starts to relax
some of those restrictions we know that
there will be people who will be getting
infected I mean that is just reality the
critical issue is to be able to in real
time identify isolate and contact trace
that's called containment right now in
places like New Orleans and in New York
City we're in mitigation so you know I
have confidence that with the help that
we can do federally from from the from
the
federal government to the fact that the
states are really committed to doing it
right I think that combination hopefully
is gonna get us to where we want to be
okay where we want to be is the question
what does where we want to be look like
so if out you finally is asked this
question and he says well I hope maybe
next month the country can take some
some steps to reopen what the hell is
that okay so what does that look like
can we hear it like what's the plan
what's the plan I think it could
probably start at least in some ways
maybe next month and again Jake it's so
difficult to make those kinds of
prediction because they always get
thrown back at you if it doesn't happen
not by you but you know by by an even
number of people we are hoping that at
the end of the month we could look
around and say okay is there any element
here that we can safely and cautiously
start pulling back on if so do it if not
then just continue to hunker down okay
so what does that even look like what
does that even look like okay then fad
she says I hope voters will be able to
go to the polls in November based on
what okay we've not even heard a plan
what the hell are we talking about like
I'm I'm fine with a brand can we have a
plan I feel like giving the Joker speech
in the dark night right everybody's okay
so long as there's a plan we need a nap
but he's right I mean like we actually
need some form of plan here and we need
to know how realistic the plan is it
can't just people screaming widespread
testing and contact tracing yes I can
say those words too it's magical but
that doesn't solve anything what system
is going to be in place to make this
stuff happen here as factory saying he
hope his voters will be able to go to
the polls in November so he's already
said he thinks that schools could open
in September and polls could be open in
November
how okay let me like really how my kids
as I've said before are six and three do
you think my kid is gonna wear a mask in
the classroom my three year old I can't
even get the kid to wear pants you think
he's gonna wear a mask in the classroom
it's not going to happen okay like like
I took him to the doctor recently and
they asked him to wear a mask and the
first thing he did was he reached off
and he pulled the mask on I put it back
on and he pulled it off and I put it on
you think you're gonna be able to go the
classrooms full of four-year-olds how
how and then here's pouchy saying that
he hopes that we'll be able to go to the
polls in November listen I hope I hope
lots of things I do but like how about
your inputs how about how we are making
these decisions it is frankly annoying
to me that nobody is even asking the
question as to how these decisions get
made what metrics are you using what
additional data do you need tell me so
we can help and don't tell me the only
way to help is just to stay home because
I don't think that's right you're asking
people to give up their livelihoods for
good in order for you to not have any
sort of plan in order for you not to
tell us how the formula works
here's pouchy saying that you hope
voters will be able to go to the polls
in November
I hope so Jake I can't guarantee it I
believe that if we have a good measured
way of rolling into this steps towards
normality that we hope by the time we
get to November that we'll be able to do
it in a way which is the standard way
however and I don't want to be the
pessimistic person there is always a
possibility as that as we get into next
fall and the beginning of early winter
that we could see a rebound okay so it
okay I mean all right thanks for thanks
for this complete level of uncertainty
now again if there's uncertainty you're
the expert tell us how we alleviate the
uncertainty that's when experts to our
experts don't just say I know the level
of uncertainty they say here's what we
can do to alleviate the uncertainty or
alternatively there's no way to we'll
leave you the uncertainty in which case
we now have to make a hard decision in
the presence of the data the assumption
is the data is what the data is what the
data are what the data are what are you
gonna do now instead we're not hearing
what we need to know we're not hearing
how we get the information we need we're
not hearing that how the decision gets
made cuz we cannot continue like this it
cannot continue now what are the media
concerned what they're concerned with
without you being mean to trump so foul
she was on with tapper on CNN and tapper
says okay well should we have locked
this thing down earlier like in February
like South Korea did and foul she says I
think it's kind of unfair to compare us
to South Korea actually that comparison
doesn't hold here is vouching attempting
to defend the president now the reason
that I bring this up is because the
headline yesterday was found she rips
Trump I'm gonna show you the clips the
people are talking about
ouchy is deliberately attempting to
avoid ripping Trump because he knows
that if he pisses off Trump then Trump
is just gonna get pissed off and not
listen to him so here is foul Qi trying
to avoid ripping Trump the media then
printed the headline foul she rips Trump
and predictably enough from then
retweeted a call to fire Falchi because
everything is idiotic and everyone's a
here is foul Qi being asked about
South Korea and attempting to avoid the
comparison if you look could you have
done something a little bit early
would have had an impact obviously but
where we are right now is the result of
a number of factors the size of the
country the heterogeneity of the country
it's I think it's a little bit unfair to
compare us to South Korea where they had
an outbreak in Daegu and they had the
capability of immediately essentially
shutting it off completely in a way that
we may not have been able to do in this
country so obviously I would have been
nice if we had a better head start but I
don't think you could say that we are
where we are right now because of one
factor it's very complicated Jake hey
now that is him attempting to avoid the
we should have just been South Korea
then foul Qi was asked about whether
lives could have been saved with her
double your own implementation he says
well I mean sure and if you'd shut down
the entire economy in December then you
would have saved a lot of lives but
that's not how political decisions get
made this was printed in the papers as
voucher ripping Trump he's working so
hard not to rep Trump here I mean watch
just just listen to it he's working
desperately hard not to rip trim because
he knows what's gonna happen you rip
Trump and then Trump threatens to fire
you every single person in the
administration knows the formula here
and he's attempting to avoid it
unsuccessfully
if the what would have what could have
it's very difficult to go back and say
that I mean obviously you could
logically say that if you had a process
that was ongoing and you started
mitigation earlier you could have saved
lives obviously no one is going to deny
that but what goes into those kinds of
decisions is is complicated but you're
right I mean obviously if we had right
from the very beginning shut everything
down it may have been a little bit
different but there was a lot of
pushback about shutting things down back
then okay so that is him attempting to
not rip Trump the media print he rips
Trump and then Trump immediately tweets
out how he wants to he retweets somebody
saying that it's out you should be fired
he said somebody tweeted out Deana for
Congress I don't know who that is
it's weeded out foul she's now saying
the Trump hit that Trump had Trump
listened to medical experts earlier he
could have saved more lives foul she was
telling people on February 29th there
was nothing to worry about it poses no
threat to the US public at large time to
hashtag fire foul she and Trump
retweeted that and they said sorry fake
news it's all on tape I ban China won't
before people spoke up Thank You oann
come on just come on come on
and just
that everybody is geared up for the is
Trump at fault game here I understand
the media are very into it the New York
Times ran an extraordinarily long piece
today about how Trump or over the
weekend about Trump's failures on the
virus and how he was warned by a bunch
of people inside the administration dr.
Carter and Carter Metro writing on the
night of January 28th in an email to the
Department of medical affairs any way
you cut it this is gonna be bad the
projected size of the outbreak already
seems hard to believe somebody that
there was a whole group that called
itself Red Dawn because they were
figuring this thing was gonna get really
bad after the 1984 movie they started
doing that you know fairly fairly early
and then Trump apparently didn't take
any of this stuff seriously the National
Security Council office responsible for
tracking pandemics received intelligence
reports in early January predicting the
spread of the virus despite Trump's
denial weeks later he was told about
January 29th memo produced by Peter
Navarro laying out the potential risks
of the pandemic half a million deaths
the Health and Human Services Secretary
Alexei czar warned Trump of the
possibility of a pandemic on January
30th by the third week in February the
administration's top public health
experts concluded they should recommend
that Americans be warned to social
distance and stay home from work the
White House instead focused on on
messaging and crucial additional weeks
went by the wayside okay all of that is
true right all of that is true the Trump
people were saying a lot of things in
the middle of all of this you know what
else was happening local officials were
also ignoring all of this because it was
so unthinkable we've done something
unprecedented in American history a more
important piece over a political that's
being ignored is called inside America's
two-decade failure to prepare for a
corona virus and they talk about how
basically every administration for
several decades has been failing on this
stuff not just from it so feels a lot
like the 9/11 Commission here was the
immediate failure and then here are all
the failures that led up to that failure
there's an article in The New York Times
last week about how de Blasio and Cuomo
didn't shut down the state until the end
of March
basically so listen I'm all up for the
what did government do wrong and my
going theory which is that everyone in
government sucks at everything and that
the chains of bureaucracy are
extraordinarily long and that it is more
likely that things go wrong than go
right in government that that theory has
yet to be defeated but with that said
the media is focus in on Trump like a
laser beam like this is what
everybody cares about right now is just
bizarre it's absolutely bizarre okay
time for a quick thing I like and then
we'll get to a thing that I hate so
things that I like today so you know my
comfort food is a baseball book so
there's a really good new baseball book
out by Jared Diamond who's the the
baseball reporter for The Wall Street
Journal it's called swing Kings and it's
all about the hitting coaches who have
completely reshaped the game of baseball
and how they have really focused on
swinging up on the wall you were always
taught when you were a kid you're
supposed to swing down on the ball
they're supposed to hack the top half of
the ball try and hit line drives and
swing Kings basically changes that it
basically talked about how its head
Williams that maybe the greatest hitter
ever had always thought you're supposed
to swing up on the ball balls coming
downhill from a mound you're supposed to
try and swing up into the ball the
reason you've seen a skyrocketing
homerun rate without steroids is because
people have been shifting their swings
dramatically it answered some questions
I had about some players that you saw
come out of nowhere and you're like
that's got to be roids right but it
turns out no they just retooled their
strings there their swings dramatically
so check it out it's a fun book it's an
easy read swing Kings the inside story
of baseball's homerun revolution so if
you're a sports person like I am and you
are missing sports right now then this
can kind of fill the gap okay time for a
quick thing that I hate so the US
Surgeon General is meningioma Adams he
happens to be black and he has been
giving these pressors and answering
questions about what Americans should do
well in the middle of one of these
pressors he was asked specifically about
the african-american communities about
Latino communities now there been tons
of articles recently like lots of them
about the disparate health impacts of
kovin 19 and those articles have been
focused heavily on the fact that black
and Latino populations have been harder
hit by coronavirus than other
populations and this has led people like
AOC to suggest that there is a disparity
in health care in the United States
that's not what's going on here that's
led people to suggest that there the
disparities in wealth have led to
disparities in health conditions some of
that has been going on here the idea is
that America is pre-existing races
America's pre-existing racism has led to
these health conditions and there is
maybe some evidence that thanks to the
wealth gap that people are poorer and if
you're poor and tend to eat less less
well you don't need as good food but
here's the reality of the situation
right now in America if you want to eat
healthy you should be able to eat
healthy
people do have welfare people do have
food stamps people do have access
generally to a grocery store even if yes
you have to take a bus over to the
grocery store that is not located in
your four block radius in any case
Jerome Adams gets up and he's talking
about some of the contributing factors
to lack of health in some minority
communities he says we need to eat
healthier we need to exercise we need to
stop if you're taking drugs you need to
stop taking drugs if you're doing
alcohol you need to stop drinking
alcohol you need to do all these things
and he's not specifically directing that
at black and Latino people but this is
taken as though he's a racist for Jerome
Adams that he is a racist he has
internalized racism for suggesting that
there are differential health outcomes
between black and Latino people in the
United States and white people in the
United States which again is I thought
what the message was for the past
several weeks the peasant message for
the past several weeks was the New York
Times headline right asteroid to hit
Earth tomorrow
women and women of minorities hit
hardest right that's been the headline
from the New York Times for a while
which is Kovan 19 affecting everyone
women and minorities hit hardest
although in this case would be men and
minorities hit hardest in any case here
was Jerome Adams here's what he said and
then the reaction was just outsized and
ridiculous
avoid alcohol tobacco and drugs and call
your friends and family checking on your
mother she wants to hear from you right
now and speaking of mothers we need you
to do this if not for yourself then for
your abuela do it for your granddaddy do
it for your Big Momma do it for your
pop-pop we need you to understand
especially in communities of color we
need you to step up and help stop the
spread so that we can protect those who
were most vulnerable he said mom he said
pop-pop and he said Big Mama or grandma
how dare he how dare he
so he's suggesting that maybe if
everybody exercise personal
responsibility including in the black
community and then he uses some some
language that he has heard in his own
upbringing right he said this he said I
used to call my grandpa hop-hop like it
and people are like oh he's a racist so
you Misha ålesund or who can always be
trusted to for a hot take she says that
Adams was being racist when he said all
of this stuff that he's being a racist
for pointing out health disparities
again you can't have it both ways either
you want tremendous focus on the health
disparities which would
include looking at things like personal
behavior inside communities and how that
is actually contributing to health
disparities like if do you eat a lot of
fast food right people in minority
communities are eating much more fast
food much more fast food than people who
are not in minority communities for
example well it depends on the minority
community minority communities in light
and like Los Angeles for example right
in the in the American South lots of
people eat fast food like all the time
in in just by studies in but overall it
has been shown that that black Americans
tend to eat fast food more than white
Americans just broadly speaking hey does
that contribute to obesity which
contributes to health effects which
actually have a problem for Kobe 19 yes
is it bad from Adams to mention this
apparently you're only supposed to
mention health disparities when you're
going to blame the system at large or
American racism writ large but when
you're talking about personal activity
and what you can do to change your risk
from covin 19 it's very bad it makes you
a racist so here's who me shouts in door
doing this routine you said African
Americans and Latinos should avoid
alcohol drugs in tobacco you'll said do
it for your wallet do it for Big Momma
language and the idea that you're saying
behaviors might be leading to these high
death rates did you talk about whether
or not people could you I guess have a
response or people who might be offended
by the language they used yeah again if
you are if you are super offended I just
want to know are we supposed to discuss
the racial disparity are we not supposed
to discuss the racial disparity and if
we do discuss the racial disparity is
your chief complaint going to be that
this black Surgeon General is a racist
for using for using language with regard
to with regard to Latino grandmothers
and grandfathers and and aunts and
uncles and like really that's what
that's where you're gonna go it seems to
me you might be missing the point
deliberately actually it seems to me
they might be deliberately missing the
point in order to focus in on narratives
that they confirm your priors which is
that American racism is is everything
when it comes to health disparities in
the United States and personal behavior
has nothing to do with anything let me
just say this white black or green if
you would like to live through kovat 19
here are a few things that you can do
you can exercise you can eat better you
cannot drink alcohol you cannot do drugs
and if you are in among a group of
people who are doing that more often
particularly young people don't do it
okay how about that and if he's asked
about health disparities and he answers
about health disparities and he uses
statistics to back it up I don't again
if you're focused in on the racism
narrative at this point in time I think
that you're completely missing the boat
it's so funny for five seconds it was
the virus unites us all and then it went
to the virus is terrible for black and
Hispanic people and if you mentioned
that there might be differentials in
behavior statistically speaking with
regard to some behaviors and that's very
very bad or if you use language
specifically to appeal to black and
Hispanic people for issues that affect
everybody because you're talking to
black and Hispanic people that's also
very bad what a stupid world we live in
seriously stupid okay so a little bit
later this afternoon apparently there
will be an announcement on a regional
reopening plan with governor's from New
Jersey Connecticut Pennsylvania Maryland
and Delaware expect that to be we're not
reopening ever expect that to be the
outcome there we will also be having
some more but what we're going to be
having some more updates on data as it
comes out a little bit later today we
have two more additional hours of
content later today otherwise show up
later tonight if you are a member of any
sort you get access for now to the
all-access live I believe I'm doing the
all-access lab tonight so we'll be
hanging out I'll be wearing a t-shirt as
is now my all-access live garb
I promise so have you been itching for a
sight of these guns I know no but but if
you were then that would be the time
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
I douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SCI events audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mina
hair and makeup is by Anika Geneva the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2020
as the corona virus doomsday models fall
apart the alarmists who pushed them are
doubling down on their draconian
policies we will examine the value of
civil disobedience when power-hungry
hypocrites get exposed and lash out then
the former Biden's staff are accusing
the presumptive Democratic presidential
nominee of sexual assault files a formal
police complaint and the mainstream
media go into full cover-up mode to
protect Jo finally we take a look at the
glaring logical fallacy at the heart of
the left's favorite coronavirus
narrative all that more check it out on
the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
you